roux c'est un de bach ils pédalent pour
contrer l'obésité
alors mon rire on pense à toi oui très
cher et l'organisateur de l'événement
voilà j'étais rendu au point que j'étais
capable de vivre en 2011 il a subi une
chirurgie bariatrique à l'institut de
cardiologie et de pneumologie de québec
il pesait alors 438 livres près de 200
kg par un âge qu'elle soit perdue 200
lits loge 30 à 242 perdre il désire
amasser des fonds afin de permettre à
d'autres personnes d'obtenir ce qu'il a
maintenant la santé le goût de vivre et
de se dépasser je ne souffre d'apnée du
sommeil
aux pressions j'ai pu de douleurs au dos
trop de douleur au genou l'argent
recueilli ira dans un fonds dédié à
l'obésité à la fondation de livres cpq
l'objectif dix mille dollars pour
financer la recherche et l'équipement ce
sapin est aussi maintenant qu'acheter
une charles pasqua personnes à la rue
cap et 400 livres on peut placer son
n'importe quel style de chansons
vraiment voir une suite adapté pour son
confort à air ainsi que pour bien mais
qui provoque ce soit endommagée la
proportion d'adultes obèses au québec
devrait atteindre 21 % d'ici 2030 une
proportion qui ne cesse d'augmenter
depuis les années 80 7% de la population
était alors touché par l'obésité la
pandémie est une des causes de cette
augmentation
plusieurs études révèlent que le
confinement à changer les habitudes
alimentaires et une baisse de l'activité
physique chez de nombreuses personnes il
est donc important de faire tomber les
tabous selon louis fréchette dans mon
corps j'assume une partie
c'est il faut pour penser non plus que
chaque personne et qu'il obèses et une
personne marche au contrat
qui subir la chirurgie c'est pour ça si
nous non plus les experts demandent des
mesures de santé publique pour
contrecarrer à long terme les
comportements liés à l'obésité et ainsi
prévenir les complications de santé ici
marie pierre mercier radio canada québec